inside this case is an actual infinity
stone this is the reality Stone made
from an actual precious gem Marvel
teamed up with East Continental gems to
bring the powerful Infinity Stones
closer to you and these collectible
reality stones are made from natural
rubies and only 300 of them are made to
collect the most insane part is that if
you collect all six Infinity Stones you
get to purchase a handcrafted Infinity
Gauntlet to place them in
see the thing is not all rubies are made
the same in fact you can get different
sizes and different cuts and you can't
expect to show about like 1500 to even
20 000 US dollars hey
man I can't believe we have our own
reality Stone now I guess we gotta catch
them all